[Applause]
[Music]
question party is very simple you guys
in the audience are going to ask me and
tara questions and we are going to
answer them and it's going to be fun
like a little party yeah which is why we
call it that
now if you have a question just raise
your hand
and if we call on you
stand up
let your voice be heard
without pulling down your mask and ask
it
yeah uh ask it nice and loud so we can
hear you but please don't pull your mask
down we're trying to answer questions
not spread germs uh look i'm trying to
say all of tarik's lines he's trying to
do it right i don't give up
okay
got two
margaritas what is [ __ ] let's do this
who has a question for me and tears oh
yeah raise your hand who's got one all
right
um
the baby in the cutest sweater hi blue
mask cute sweater yes
oh it's a sweater dress
i love it
oh my god it's the season for sweater
dresses
okay hi
hi i'm so excited to be here um
i just wanted to know like what's your
favorite song or what do you choose the
music
or what
great great question great question
favorite song this is a tough one
sweater dress damn oh the higher the
fashion the tougher the question yes
i guess what are we talking about here
favorite
song
[Music]
favorite
song
is
one
[Music]
the boxing thing
honestly it's probably back that ass up
and i wish i was joking yeah
uh it looks like
if it's in terms of what happens to your
body when the song hits your ears it's
back that um yeah for me it's ludicrous
is how low can you go you should see
this boy all right i know yeah you think
you know terry but when that song plays
you yeah i don't know myself
how low can you
oh go come on we can't be singing this
song we can't it's my fault that ain't
gonna ever gonna air so we're gonna air
you guys
who has another question hi wow hi last
lady what's your question
where do i get these suits from
great question oh thank you
yes
um when i uh when we got this show i
said to eric justian who has always
worked on late night seth and so have i
this has been seven years now and he's
worked 500 years on snow and i said i
want to
wear
a suit i want to look as fancy as i can
look while being a girl in a suit and i
like bows
that is
the that is everything i said to this
man he said how do you want to look i
said oh you know like kurt hummel from
glee
[Applause]
you guys
thank you for asking these questions and
thank you for being here okay that is
all the time we have for question party
this was great should we do it again
sometime
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you